[Musique]
où est-ce qu'on est aujourd'hui on est
sur un circuit je sais pas si vous le
voyez bien on est dans le sud de la
France on est au Circuit Paul Rica sur
le soleil en pleine tranche tout va bien
regardez là le soleil est là-bas et
derrière moi il y a des voitures des
voitures des Audi alors vous connaissez
Audi rien vous apprendre dessus par
contre ce qui est super cool c'est que
Audi m'a dit tiens mon beau monsieur
gros est-ce que tu voudrais pas venir
pendant 2 jours parce qu'en fait on va
venir tester les technologies on va vous
montrer les technologies de Audi ok donc
vous allez voir on va se balader dans
cette vidéo pour regarder plein de
choses différentes technologies on va
regarder effectivement des technologies
au niveau de la conduite on est sur le
circuit on va aller se balader on va
regarder technologie d'affichage on va
regarder technologie de lumière on va
regarder plein de trucs vous allez voir
vous allez voir c'est passionnant donc
accrochez-vous mettez votre ceinture
posez-vous vraiment à l'aise parce que
ça va secouer aujourd'hui je vous le
cache pas on va se faire un tour de
bagnole de fou on va rouler sur circuit
pas que sur circuit on va faire du
Offroad on va aller dans des cailloux on
va les mettre les voitures dans de la
flotte bref on va aller secouer et on va
regarder les techno de Audi vous allez
voir c'est une vidéo un peu à part je
trouve ça extrêmement intéressant et je
compte sur vous pour me dire ce que vous
en pensez dans les commentaires
[Musique]
donc là on va monter en TTS pas mal
regardez-moi ça là faites voir hop yes
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire là comme
atelier là j'ai pas capté différence
technologies quattro sur une surface de
faible adhérence
[Musique]
je vous explique ce qu'on fait là donc
là c'est le premier atelier alors il y a
plusieurs groupes on est répartis sur le
circuit du Castelet bref je passe un peu
le truc le premier atelier c'est de
venir voir le côté quattro les quattro
les quatre roues motrices grosse
technologie ici maîtrisée parodie alors
lorsque vous laissez électronique vous
voyez franchement ça tient le pavé ça
bouge pas enfin ça bouge pas parce que
toi tu es limite et lorsque vous
désactivez l'électronique ça chasse du
cul non de dieu ça part et il y a même
il y a même une autre techno qui vous
permet de venir mettre tout le couple du
moteur sur une seule roue par exemple
une seule roue arrière et là lorsqu'on
fait des cercles comme ça c'est encore
pire de pire alors moi je suis pas du
tout un pilote hein donc c'est pas moi
qui vais vous la faire mais en terme de
sensation le truc est démentiel deux
tours connectés complet au moins comme
ça on va voir un petit peu la différence
donc là tu vas dire du Braque du Braque
juste sur braque vraiment il accélère
franchement
[Musique]
la vache donc le torcière ça veut dire
que ça fait pas ça me met un peu plus de
puissance à l'arrière
qui va être la roue arrière extérieure
en fonction une seule
[Musique]
la plus belle Lego c'est de ressentir
justement la différence des systèmes
quattro
c'est vraiment vraiment différente
[Musique]
on ouvre le volant et on sort bien
l'argent on sort là je peux utiliser
tout à l'heure je rêve il faut tout le
temps rester les mains à 9h15 comme ça
tu es sûr d'avoir les palettes derrière
et là tu peux accélérer
[Musique]
220 j'ai jamais fait ça de ma vie reste
bien à gauche encore à gauche encore à
gauche frein deuxième et ouvre ton
volant et tu peux accélérer
[Musique]
c'est ouf complet
donc là on se fait une épreuve pour
montrer que ça passe partout toutes les
routes que ce soit de l'électrique de
l'hybride là on se fait ça sur un
terrain et la regarder là on va la faire
passer là-dedans alors il va il attaque
la vache je crois que là ça va la
refroidir correctement c'est ouf ici
j'ai jamais vu une Audi nager je crois
que je peux dire que cette fois-ci elle
nage celle-là j'aurais jamais pensé
faire du 4x4 avec une Audi comme ça quoi
voilà c'est fou mais tu dis je vais
l'abîmer je vais tu risques pas là
d'abîmer sur les suspensions sur les
pneumatiques soit rien faisant ça
veut dire sur les pneumatiques et c'est
toujours mieux
et là regarde tu as marqué Larry dans la
montée
c'est vrai que c'est impressionnant
parce que tu aurais tendance à te dire
il faut que je joue avec le point de
patinage et bah non du coup il y a plus
besoin parce que il y a pas d'engage
j'ai l'impression de faire une balade le
dimanche mais dans la forêt en voiture
là on va se faire l'aide à la descente
c'est quoi la descente
ouais je le vois
tu valides cette vitesse et donc là tu
vois elle va stabiliser à 7 km/h ah oui
j'attends qu'il freine un peu là donc
elle reste à 7 km/h pour que je sois à
la cool
si j'accélère un peu
accélérateur elle me garde à cette
vitesse là ok donc j'ai pas besoin de ma
[ __ ] celle qui gère la vitesse toute
seule et donc là il voit que je suis
plus en descente il a désactivé elle est
plus verte ok quand c'est qu'un
gyroscope à l'intérieur en fait
activer ou non
[Musique]
ça va dehors
tu es en dynamique un chioti ça veut
dire que tu es en mode en mode sport il
y a pas plus de typé sport allez pieds
sur le frein et on va y aller
400 chevaux et on est sur le fameux cinq
cylindres moteurs transversal
par rapport à la salle d'avance c'est
c'est différent c'est l'avantage que tu
as c'est qu'il y a en quatre mots triste
donc ça va mieux tenir la route
allez frein tout de suite à droite
quatrième allez accélère et 4
plus fort plus fort voilà et de moins en
moins voilà mais ne lâche pas tout d'un
coup parce que là tu vas être obligé
d'en remettre un freinage ça se fait une
seule fois
donc là on peut venir piloter la voiture
avec le smartphone ça veut dire qu'avec
ton smartphone tu peux lui dire sans du
stationnement ou alors gare-toi
exactement avec ton application à l'idée
c'est j'arrive à ma voiture par exemple
quelqu'un s'est garé derrière je peux
pas charger mes bagages dans le coffre
plutôt que de monter dans la voiture
pour la sortir après redescendre la
voiture pour charger mes bagages mais de
l'extérieur grâce à mon smartphone je
peux sortir ma voiture de stationnement
ou alors je peux la rentrer en créneau
aussi si je veux la grande créneau avec
mon smartphone donc là tu viens
d'arriver avec ta bagnole tu l'as posé
tu as un stationnement là une voiture là
une voiture là la place pour peser là on
va dire que tu es pas bon pour venir te
garer elle va se garer pour toi
démarrer donc le stationnement à
distance et toujours pareil appuyez sur
P si je maintiens mon doigt appuyé sur P
la manœuvre va se faire dès que j'enlève
mon doigt du P la voiture s'arrête
toujours le doigt dessus en fait et là
elle se gare toute seule
c'est ouf
faut que tu sois pas loin pour qu'elle
continue à te capter OK et là elle se
gare toute seule comme une robe et là si
je me mets devant elle va s'arrêter
le doigt continue sa main d'oeuvre voilà
c'est ça c'est fou complet
[Musique]
donc là maintenant on va se faire juste
un petit tour de voiture de course juste
on grimpe là dedans c'est la RS3 LMS
c'est hyper impressionnant c'est à dire
qu'en fait à l'arrière il y a rien moi
qui suis un novice vous pouvez expliquer
en fait à quoi ça sert tout ça comment
ça fonctionne ici la boîte ou une moto
sur l'avant ou sur l'arrière d'accord
donc ça change la balance de la voiture
mais ça vous le fait dès le départ par
roulant on peut le faire en roulant on
peut le faire en gros on peut le faire
en roulant chaud
le comportement de la voiture en
fonction de du grip que l'on a ok en
roulant ensuite ça c'est le
coupe-circuit général le contact les
phares les clignotants le frein à main
sur une seule roue à l'arrière pour les
phases de départ et après il manque le
volant c'est pratique le volant d'accord
donc équipé comme ça et le volant il
vient vraiment à la fin une fois qu'on
est positionné quoi voilà exactement ça
facilite l'entrée dans la voiture pour
s'installer dans le paquet et donc là
vous communiquez avec la radio
directement et en liaison radio parce
que le bruit est un petit peu trop
fort
vous vous avez des trucs pour vous
appuyer pour vos pieds les appuis un
petit cale-pied je me sens bien surtout
c'est important
c'est incroyable tu as déjà fait ça toi
c'était très sympa et j'adore
[Musique]
que les autres voitures en fait ça n'a
rien à voir avec une voiture de course
et ben bon courage je te regarde partir
à tout à l'heure c'est très
impressionnant c'est fou complet je
trouve ça dingue mais regardez il va
nous faire un petit départ là allez bon
courage
alors c'est comment ça sent le chaud tu
as appuyer un peu non un petit peu c'est
une voiture de course donc ok j'ai mis
les packs de Vital derrière merci
beaucoup monsieur merci c'est très
gentil
j'ai jamais monté dans un véhicule comme
celui-là c'est quand même foot de faire
un stade un volant
[Musique]
j'ai des crampes dans les pouces
c'est incroyable merci beaucoup c'est
fou complet je suis pas du tout pilote
vraiment pas en terme de sensation c'est
[Musique]
donc là l'idée effectivement c'est la
conduite prédictive c'est à dire qu'on
met le régulateur à 90 et elle la
bagnole elle va conduire toute seule et
ah oui effectivement donc là elle freine
bien dans le virage seul touche à rien
donc comment elle fait là en fait pour
analyser la des caméras qui vont
caméra donc là je touche absolument rien
d'accord donc là
tu vois lui c'est un virage rapide là tu
es un peu trop tôt réellement
trajectoire
et va réduire la vitesse d'accord ok la
ligne droite la réaccélérer et là je
vais où on va aller à droite et regarde
elle va le faire toute seule tu as juste
à tourner ah oui est-ce que tu l'as mis
le GPS c'est pour ça
vu qu'on est sur un circuit il y a des
raccordements partout c'est pour lui
faire comprendre que je passais par ici
avec mes règles à 200
là elle freine elle nous tombe toute
seule sur circuit au régulateur et quand
même un peu bizarre l'histoire non au
début c'est un freinage qui est
confortable qui est agréable dans
l'ennemi tu peux gérer que ce soit sur
du tardif de l'anticiper c'est
progressif là
mais tu peux choisir qu'elle puisse
commencer à freiner plutôt ou plus tard
alors sensation c'est cool
tout à l'heure mais c'est un peu
différent
[Musique]
donc là c'est l'expérience électrique
sur de Lightroom on est sur quelle
voiture là il trône RS GT on a combien
de chevaux sous le capot
588 et avec le boost 646 646 avec le
blues bordel voilà ça part fort quoi
[Musique]
juste l'accélérateur pour faire de la
recharge on va freiner dans l'idée si on
ne courbe rapide comme ça c'est d'avoir
une vitesse constante ok c'est à dire tu
vas lâcher le frein au moment où tu mets
ton braquage d'accord et tu remets les
gaz pour garder cette vitesse et là tu
peux débraquer écraser ok une droite
c'est facile ça va tout droit c'est le
panneau qui m'a indiqué limite à 80 km
heure je suis déjà à 210
voilà bien restez le long de ta ligne
blanche à gauche et au point de braquage
j'ai déclenché le mouvement pour rentrer
dans le virage
et c'est là qu'on se rend compte que
avec une voiture de plus de tonne 300 de
ton 3 c'est là de ton 400 et quelques on
arrive quand même à rouler très très
vite c'est marrant je vous mettrai
soufflé alors je suis assis
et là tu lâches accélérateur et on
laisse aller la voiture parfait génial
très bien bravo
[Musique]
vous pouvez venir d'où moduler
directement au niveau de vos éclairages
avant c'est super marrant alors toute la
partie que vous voyez que les petits
logos là effectivement le petit logo
audit éclairé pour l'instant c'est pas
dit que ça arrive à cause de la
législation mais en tout cas c'est super
chouette et on va retrouver la même
chose au niveau de l'arrière il y a
personnaliser complètement l'expérience
à l'avant et également l'arrière sont
des feux à base de technologie OLED ça
permet de faire un peu tout ce qu'on
veut je trouve ça super joli super
élégant une fois de plus le logo éclairé
on est vraiment pas sûr que ça arrive
mais dans l'idée de venir personnaliser
son véhicule d'utiliser la technologie
OLED directement pour pouvoir dessiner
ce qu'on veut et avoir une voiture qui
est vraiment à part c'est génial en fait
dans l'Audi A8 il y a détecteur d'angle
mort qui fait que si il détecte un
piéton ou un vélo qui arrive la poignée
elle a une partie électrique et du coup
ça va temporiser l'ouverture de la porte
dans un premier temps pas pouvoir ouvrir
la tête au vélo on peut pas le mettre
dans la tête au vélo si un vélo et qu'on
n'aime pas sa tête on peut pas lui
mettre d'accord ok donc si je vous
renverse c'est quelqu'un j'ai pas le
droit c'est bien c'est sécurisé
donc avec les projecteurs qui sont les
projecteurs d'origine de la voiture avec
ses projecteurs là en fait on peut
projeter au mur un jeu qui est issu de
la voiture donc ça en fait ça veut dire
que lorsque je suis en train d'attendre
j'ai une petite manette je peux jouer
directement à la console et je projette
avec les femmes en jeu c'est un peu
bizarre mais c'est marrant alors il faut
trouver le bon mur ne pas le mettre sur
une fenêtre en quoi les gens ont fait un
peu la gueule mais ça me fait un petit
jeu noir et blanc en fait avec les
phares et avec une manette de Xbox ah
c'est ça c'est la partie en bas en fait
donc c'est ça qui projette le jeu que
celui-là il y a que celui-là
ah ouais ah ouais ok ça c'est super
super drôle quoi là on la voit je vous
cache pas avec un peu plus de lumière la
future A6 le concept car alors là vous
voyez c'est des petits rétros numériques
en fait qui permettent alors ils m'ont
dit ça c'est vachement marrant parce que
c'est tiré trop numérique qui vous
permet de gagner en autonomie parce que
fatalement vous avez un peu moins de de
prise au vent et s'améliore
fondamentalement l'aérodynamisme et
regardez moi ça là je vous la montre on
fait un petit tour un petit tour du
bestiau qui est super joli et même là
avec la lumière et pourquoi est-ce que
les phares franchement l'éclairage ça en
jette vraiment on est vraiment sur un
concept car attention on se parle d'un
véhicule qui arrivera en 2023 alors
peut-être pas en l'état parce qu'une
fois de plus il y a toute la loi venir
respecter la législation le si le ça
mais elle est juste hyper canon
on va aussi se parler technologie au
niveau du cadre du véhicule qui font
depuis les années je vous dise pas de
bêtises depuis les années 90 sur
certains véhicules en aluminium
certaines finitions d'aluminium et là
vous avez un cadre en aluminium de la A8
D3 alors c'est despoque c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui mais le truc qui était
vraiment révolutionnaire à l'époque
c'est que c'était pas du tout on a eu
avant la luminum a porté forcément de la
légèreté alors avec du magnésium et du
silicium si je dis pas de bêtises donc
le truc à porter beaucoup de légèreté et
surtout le truc était vraiment
révolutionnaire qui a fait Audi à
l'époque c'est qu'en fait à l'avant au
niveau de votre véhicule et bien vous
avez cette partie là lorsque vous aviez
un accident et bien ça venir rentrer à
l'intérieur et ça permettait vraiment
d'absorber les chocs alors aujourd'hui
ça parait normal mais en tout cas à
l'époque c'était pas le cas ça c'est
très chouette ça donner naissance à ce
véhicule là véhicule là qui est tout en
aluminium alors là on se parle du modèle
qui était là avant la A8 et qui est un
concept car donc j'ai bouffé le nom
c'est quoi le nom du concept car alors
la vue souhait et celle là qu'on est en
face à c'était la 8 après
8D de 1994 alors ça reste un concept car
mais après les sorties effectivement
sous la à 8 et vous la voyez même la
carrosserie elle est juste Dingo Dingo
et là on a la Avus alors ça c'est un
truc qu'on peut pas y toucher c'est un
concept car de dingue c'est un véhicule
qui a roulé on se parle ici d'une
voiture de 1991 un look absolument
incroyable qui est toujours extrêmement
rasé pour voir qu'on est aujourd'hui
quand même en 2022 on se parle d'une
bagnole qui a presque bondage pas tout à
fait mais presque mon âge et qui est
juste magnifique donc regardez le truc
c'est absolument fou alors à l'intérieur
on a du bon vieux cuir d'époque on a du
bon vieux bois d'arbre et on a de la
laine voilà mais sinon c'est juste fou
alors au-delà du côté un peu vintage de
ce véhicule qui est complètement fou et
encore très très contemporain jusqu'à
les optiques en fait qui le vieillissent
vraiment ce qui est intéressant c'est la
technologie au niveau du cadre une
voiture qui a une gueule absolument
dingue 0 à 100 en 3 secondes bref un
truc de fou furieux et qu'on retrouve et
surtout qu'on peut jamais voir donc
c'est génial de pouvoir l'avoir ici
[Musique]
voilà pour cette expérience partagée sur
le circuit Paul Ricard pas très loin de
Marseille pas vraiment mais pas très
loin bon comment vous dire alors vous
avez vu il y a plein de choses
intéressantes chez Audi plein de
technologie au niveau des véhicules
électriques thermiques également c'est
intéressant parce que cette opportunité
que d'un Audi à venir voir et à
découvrir leur technologie sous
différents angles c'est cool parce que
c'est une façon de comprendre l'ADN de
la marque parce que l'ADN de la marque
il est construit depuis plus d'un siècle
plus d'un siècle mais pas loin je pense
en tout cas depuis très longtemps sur
l'innovation c'est une marque innove
énormément et qui apporte beaucoup dans
le secteur de l'automobile fatalement
donc je trouve ça très chouette je suis
très heureux d'avoir partagé ça avec
vous dites moi ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous avez aimé vivre cette
expérience est-ce que vous trouvez ça
intéressant que je vous montre des fois
un peu alors c'est pas vraiment des
coulisses mais de comprendre les techno
d'une marque après faut dire que c'est
pas moi qui est sollicité c'est vraiment
Audi qui m'a proposé de venir ici avec
plein de copains journalistes le
créateur de contenu le truc est fou
furieux je suis très heureux de l'avoir
partagé avec vous et je vous cache pas
qu'il y a une petite émotion palpable
parce que j'étais en train de de
conduire là voiture du course waouh un
moment je me dis ouais j'ai vraiment
beaucoup d'émotions et c'était voilà
incroyable voilà bon allez je vous
embrasse très heureux de partager ça
avec vous à bientôt ciao ciao
[Musique]